[Musik]
werde ich mal die Kiste dran und öffnen
die mal hier komm mal hier sieht die für
dich irgendwie komisch aus wenn du dich
hier hinstellst
alles klar das gibt die fetteste Kampf
an dein Haus wird brennen
weißt du was jetzt passiert guck zu
genießt die Show
beim brennt das nicht
das ist ein Streichholz
und Fackeln denkt das ist ein
Streichholz
schlafen gehen
und dann in der Hölle wir könnten dir
diesen Hut wieder mitnehmen
[Musik]
hinter dir
Links
und jetzt können wir los oder
egal du siehst halt nicht so viel
ja aber dann wenn du damit kannst du for
real Enderman angucken
tut mir leid kann man nichts machen
ne
Leute entschuldigung ich habe aus
Versehen Sandra erschossen
lauf lauf lauf lauf zu mir vorbei
du lebst noch alles gut alles Gute
wir müssen dieses Biom finden wo die
Enderman sind warum denn
da die ganzen Enderman sind doch ich
glaube es ist am sinnvollsten Sandy wenn
du einfach ein bisschen auf die Suche
gehst nach Quarz einfach ganz vorsichtig
niemanden angreifen aber wenn dich einer
angreift dann das Schild benutzen was du
in anderen Hand hält
ja scheiß auf dich und ich suche mal
eben kurz mit Speed hier so ein Wald und
dann würde ich dich einfach
teleportieren
hey ich weiß nicht wo so ein Wald sein
soll Leute soll ich mal okay Bio machen
dass wir gucken wo so ein Wald ist dass
wir zumindest die Richtung kennen
okay
300 Blöcke entfernt nur 300 Blöcke
entfernen das total wenig genau hier
sind wir doch her gelaufen oder bin ich
blöd
ist Moment
Leute ich bin in der Luftballon runter
das Handy ich bin in der Luft ich bin
tot wenn ich jetzt weiter klicke ich
wollte da drüber springen ich dachte ich
schaffe das leider was machen wir denn
jetzt Sandy du kannst mich zu dir tippen
aber ich die Frage ist ob wir das machen
wollen leute das ist halt schon wieder
cheaten wir machen das nicht
[Musik]
sorry aber das kann doch nicht wahr sein
Handy also folgende Situation ich war in
der Luft ich bin gesprungen und hat dann
gesehen ich schaffe es nicht auf den
Block ich habe direkt escape gedrückt
bin ins Menü gegangen und habe dann
überlegt was ich mache und in dem Moment
wo ich in der Luft war kam ein Schwein
an und hat nicht komplett runtergekickt
ich weiß dass das Geld nicht
funktioniert im Multiplayer ach lol
dann war ich ja wirklich auf dem Blog
dann bin ich doch nicht so blöd wie
gedacht aber nicht trotzdem jetzt wäre
ich dann halt gestorben aber ich glaube
Leute dann sind wir uns ja einig dadurch
dass ich auf dem Blog stand war sie
einfach nur eine Verwechslung
dementsprechend ist es ja eigentlich
nicht schlimm wenn ich mir jetzt
Gamemode gibt glaube ich oder
Mods könnte kurz eine Umfrage machen
cheaten ja nein um Frage ist ganz klar
ja ich soll cheaten
ich schreibe mir das vor und drück
direkt enter wenn du online gehst ja das
würde ich auch sagen ich mache es jetzt
Handy ich mache es ich mach's ich mach's
ich bin drauf verbindet zum Server so
komm ganz schnell
ich drück ganz schnell Tee
bin creative hab's geschafft ich will
einmal ganz kurz sehen wo ich war von
hier gekommen ich bin hier rüber
gelaufen
dann stand ich hier auf einem Block
drauf oder was ja ist jetzt auch nicht
so schlimm gewesen wenn ich gestorben
weil ich hatte jetzt auch nicht so
krasse Sachen aber so Sachen wie mit dem
Bogen mit Stärke 4 Unendlichkeit das ist
halt blöd boah Leute okay das war das
erste und einzige Mal dass wir jetzt für
mich gecheatet haben das wird auch so
bleiben
hier irgendwo sein oder Leute
ich mache mir in die Hose aber es muss
doch hier lang sein wenn ich mich jetzt
recht in Sinne
411 - 411 63 Blöcke in die Richtung
müsste jeden Moment da sein dann kannst
du mir holen okay noch 100 Blöcke
ein Drittel haben wir schon ein paar
Sekunden später
Leute
zu mir
endlich und jetzt müssen wir irgendwo
Enderman sein
[Musik]
jeder doch rein
oh nein
wo rein in mein Boot soll da reingehen
ich habe eine Perle einfach und das
müssen wir jetzt nur 16 mal machen
wie viele enderperlen hast du jetzt
sieben Leute wie viel brauchen wir 12 ne
16 brauchen wir warum denn 16 ja Ciao
Kakao falls welche kaputt genau
ja Leute ich glaube ich logge mich genau
hier aus und dann suche ich in der
nächsten Folge noch mal weiter ich werde
jetzt auf jeden Fall mich genau hier
ausloggen und ähm
dementsprechend den Minecraft Stream für
heute beenden Laser Leute täterino ich
gehe jetzt mal offline ich wünsche euch
den besten Tag Abend noch tschüss leute
danke für den Stream wirklich von Real
danke nochmal für eure ganzen lieben
Kommentare zu meiner Frisur wann der
nächste Stream ist erfahrt ihr am besten
dadurch indem ihr mir bei Twitch folgt
ist kostenlos könnt ihr einfach hier
folgen ich kriege dafür auch nichts aber
einfach nur dann das in der
Benachrichtigung bekommt wenn ich live
gehe danke für eure Support danke für
die meisten stream
[Musik]